technology is like Pandora's box once
it's open you can't really close it
there is gonna be a downside to this
technological progress automation is
gonna further concentrate wealth in the
hands of the few who own the robots we
need to think of a new social structure
new being the purposes for human beings
I think ultimately we will have to have
some kind of universal basic income I
don't think we can have a choice
[Music]
do you think that we're in a danger zone
definitely I think any conversation
about artificial general intelligence or
like robots taking over is a distraction
to the real question that we have to
answer which is what are we going to do
about the people whose jobs are
displaced I'm at a Silicon Valley
Robotics Show with Adam Cal a partner at
a venture capital firm that focuses on
artificial intelligence and robotics
techies like Adam are battling it out to
own the machines that will replace jobs
like lawyers loan officers doctors and
truck drivers the result is likely to be
a radical deepening of inequality that
could challenge our very ideas about the
nature of work there are bigger
questions about what will happen to
capitalism when scarcity is no longer
kind of a factor because that's what
we're talking about I mean like when we
build the tools that can you know fully
automate these processes then we're not
limited by human labor to be able to put
stuff together millions of people are
expected to lose careers in the next
decade from various forms of automation
if you think about mobile phones like
they totally changed us as consumers but
they didn't really change the way work
was done this new generation of
technology is is absolutely going to do
that San Francisco with its tech
industry dominance and crushing housing
crisis is a window into the inequality
of today we're tired of standing on
these corners we want Nikes and we want
pampers for kids just like everyone else
does but we have not been afforded
opportunity to walk in these tech
cathedrals
delcie Moore worked his way out of
homelessness and founded a group that
trains low-income workers and homeless
for tech jobs they've had success
stories but it's an uphill battle well
of course is frustration I hang on
outside I mean we're like a little kid
in the in the Dickens novels the
homeless Keita standing outside we're
looking through the window while people
are sitting there carving the steak
that's how we feel every day jobs in
trucking fast food and factories have
long been avenues for those without
higher education to have a middle-class
living or simply to stay afloat if you
had an environment with only automated
systems basically orders would come in
from from the e-commerce side the robot
would go pick the item put it in the
tote
the the items would then be put into a
box and then a label would be
automatically play something you
obviously wouldn't need any people in
that environment yeah yeah yeah they
just find that they'll go around you
yeah so they can replan on the fly and
make decisions about where to go and
what to do
Melanie wise is CEO of Phet robotics a
company that specializes in automated
warehouse robots it's something that a
lot of warehouse managers want or you
can turn the lights off in a facility
and just have it operating without any
people in it I asked Melanie if she
thought her robots could reduce jobs one
of the biggest like things that the
industry is trying to tackle right now
is there's not enough people to do the
work hiring has been on a steady upward
trajectory as jobs and warehouses have
largely replaced jobs in the
brick-and-mortar retail industry but
that could change as sales of warehouse
and logistics robots increase to twenty
two point four billion dollars by 2021
up from less than two billion in 2016 we
need to rethink capitalism itself and we
have another five years seven years
before it gets ugly
but after five is a five to ten year
period we will start to see turmoil and
we will have to start thinking about
this it's time to start learning and
adapting right now economic fears have
prompted some to prepare for the
possibility of societal collapse
Adam Taggart gave up his job at Yahoo to
prepare for drastic changes that he sees
as inevitable those with the money and I
realized this is the point zero zero one
percent we're talking about but are
buying retreat properties either here in
America or internationally and I think
that got people's attention of all right
these are legit smart people what do
they know that we don't know some in the
tech world have bought secret getaways
bunkers and guns to prepare for collapse
there are minority though the concerns
are widespread here's the former chief
economist of the Senate Banking
Committee
in a number of realms we are socially
and resource and financially
unsustainable and those unsustainability
tend to climax in some kind of violence
unless they're preempted with
intelligent policy policy solutions have
been plunging the country deeper into
inequality even as it has become a
central political issue this growing
inequality not just a result in equality
of opportunity there's growing
inequality it's not just morally wrong
it's bad economics so should tech
leaders stop innovating or working
towards these advancements I wanted to
ask Silicon Valley's inventors these
questions those creating the labor
saving robots of the future we automate
what we can automate right we're gonna
keep doing that that's how we get more
productive we've been doing that for
thousands of years robots are about 50
years old the last 15 years have been
really an explosion in terms of the
technology and the last three or four
years have been an explosion in terms of
investment in robotics worldwide annual
spending on AI is expected to increase
from 12 billion in 2017 to nearly 60
billion in 2021 we can sit back and say
we don't want to adopt robots we want to
protect jobs and that's great China will
basically build everything for us for
the foreseeable future for those
involved in building these technologies
it's an all-out battle cousins makes a
robot Butler that is being used for
deliveries and workspaces like offices
hospitals and hotels my name is Andy
Evers I'm the general manager here at
the Alam Cupertino
you're in Cupertino California and right
next to the Apple Campus on the
overnight shift we have one person
staffing the front desk so it's very
convenient for the staff to be able to
put things into the relay robot and have
it delivered to the room
you know the robots if we can get them
to figure out how to you know clean the
floors and and deliver items to rooms
and make beds then that's great
they've just allow us to offer more
service to our guests Silicon Valley is
a testing ground for technologies that
have changed our lives and a window into
unintended downsides it's also where
some of the fiercest political debates
are beginning over our automated future
it's one of the biggest issues that's
facing this country over the next decade
and not enough people are talking about
it that's Jane Kim a San Francisco City
Supervisor running for mayor who has
proposed a robot tax to help correct the
inequality that is now a defining
characteristic of the Bay Area San
Francisco has the fastest growing income
gap between the rich and the poor of any
city in the country the income gap
comparing annual pay between the
wealthiest and poorest 20% grew in San
Francisco by more than $70,000 in five
years that has made San Francisco into a
city with glittering tech towers fancy
cars and multi-million dollar homes on
every street I want to say that I do
think automation is a good thing it's a
positive thing it's gonna increase our
productivity it's gonna grow our economy
it's gonna you know help save lives and
maybe even fight climate change but
there is gonna be a downside to this
technological progress Automation is
going to further concentrate wealth in
the hands of the few who owned the
robots tech companies employ relatively
few people when compared to the
corporate behemoths of the past
at its height Kodak was worth 28 billion
and employed a hundred and forty
thousand people when Instagram was sold
to Facebook for 1 billion there were
just 13 employees Blockbuster Video
employed 60,000 people at its peak in
2004 on revenue of 5.9 billion while
Netflix employs just 44 hundred people
on revenue of 2.5 billion
much of this innovation has been
subsidized for decades by taxpayer
dollars and so we are where we at
because we have all contributed to the
research and development of automation
Kim's robot tax has been fiercely
opposed by many in the tech world
yeah let's tax innovation good idea
IIIi don't think it's a good idea you
shouldn't stop innovation because you're
afraid that rich people will get richer
what you should do is figure out how you
can make all of us wealthier and then
talk about redistribution in ways that
make sense if you don't put some ideas
out there even if they're ones that
people hate or have strong reactions to
then you're not going to be able to push
a dialog and get people to move on a
really important issue in San Francisco
the situation is dire a family of four
here making under a hundred and five
thousand per year is now considered low
income by the US Department of Housing
and Urban Development the housing crisis
in the area is so severe that many have
simply left or fallen into homelessness
Darnell Clark grew up in East Palo Alto
the heart of Silicon Valley
surrounded by the headquarters of Apple
Facebook and Google I always thought
that on East Palo Alto could use some
more companies you know it's prestigious
as Facebook is you know but I hate what
them coming to the community has done to
it
our nel couldn't afford to rent a home
in the area so he moved his family into
an RV a lot of people who live in
motorhomes are taxpayers you know they
work every day they have families that
they're trying to raise the RV's have
become an option of last resort for
working poor as rents in the area have
skyrocketed I'm just grateful that our
my children
they love us and love what we are what
we bring to him as inequality has
worsened nationwide and automation has
spurned fears of social collapse some
tech Titans have suggested a social
safety net of free money known as
universal basic income our robot tax
proposal is just one of many tools that
we're considering in a portfolio of
policies to address automation and I'm
certainly looking at universal basic
income as well the idea is simple give
every citizen guaranteed income with no
strings attached people might say oh we
don't want to give handouts but giving
handouts there's nothing shameful about
giving handouts or receiving them in a
situation where you have vast amounts of
new wealth creation but it's not an idea
that comes without controversy and gives
no incentive to work because all the
kind of reasons why you don't work that
would be a tragedy that would be
that would be that oh my god no no no
now when you look at automation it makes
it product better
it makes the efficiency of the of the
factory better it makes for a faster
delivery of of the product but you still
have to have a very advanced staff to
maintain those robots still some of the
biggest names in the tech crowd are
supporting the idea of universal basic
income I think ultimately we will have
to have some kind of universal basic
income I don't think we're gonna have a
choice and now it's time for our
generation to define a new social
contract the question now is will we
prepare for the change that seems sure
to be headed our way
the experts academics tech leaders are
all sounding the same alarm bell which
is that automation is going to destroy
certain jobs and tasks
and I think it's incredibly important
that those that are reaping the benefits
of this technological progress
contribute their share to address the
downsides as well hey I'm Joel with aj+
make sure to subscribe for more Doc's
just like this thanks for watching part
3 I hope you'll watch part 1 & 2 as well